hi i'm jenny and today i'd like to show
you how to use the apogee adapter for
envoy together with a service mesh
to integrate envoy based services into
your apogee environment
in this demo i'll show you how to use
envoy to protect a microservice
i'll add an envoy facade on it which is
configured to talk to the apogee adapter
for envoy
let's dive in i have a kubernetes
cluster that has a few applications
running the one we'll focus on for this
demo is the microservice called orders
by default there is no restriction on
who can access this microservice
let me demonstrate that by accessing it
as a consumer
to simulate a consumer i have a curl
application running in client
once i am logged into the client
application i will access the orders
microservice
based on this result i was able to
access it without passing through any
security credentials
now let me walk you through how you can
enforce the security policy so that a
consumer
must use credentials within a service
mesh to do that
i'll enable an envoy filter
i've created a file that describes all
the security policies i want to enforce
on the orders microservice
for instance i'm enforcing a policy that
requests must go through the apogee
adapter
i'm now applying this policy via the
filter
now i'm going to access the orders
microservice again
like i did before
this time i got an error a 403 forbidden
because i didn't have a security
credential let's fix that
we'll do this through the api products
in apogee
i've already created an orders api
product which is bound to the endpoint
orders running on port 8080
i've also created an application that
allows me to access the credentials for
the orders microservice
let's access the orders microservice
again this time with the api key
i'm using an api key but you could also
use an access token instead
success i was able to access the
microservice
through all these interactions analytics
are being collected and transmitted to
the apigee control panel
looking at the api metrics here you'll
notice that the orders microservice is
getting requests and i can view the data
for that
this is how you can use the apogee
adapter for envoy to enforce policies
for any service that's using envoy
within a service
mesh if you found this demo helpful
check out our introductory apogee
adapter for envoy video
linked in the description below and for
more information like codelabs and blog
posts
check out these links thanks for
[Music]
watching